c'est ici dans cette descente menant au
garage de la maison familiale que le
corps du petit garçon a été retrouvé
hier en milieu de matinée au moment du
drame l'endroit a été recouvert par de
mtres d'eau boueuse l'enfant qui se
promenait dans le jardin aurait glissé
avant de tomber à l'eau alors que les
pompiers procédaient à des opérations
d'épuisement dans deux maisons voisines
sa pompier est arrivée et entendu la
maman se s'est crié en disant mon enfant
est tombé dans
l'eau donc à rapatrier tout son
personnel et de là tout le monde a sauté
à l'eau pour récupérer l'enfant un jeune
homme de 16 ans qui avait plongé a
retrouvé l'enfant a donné dans les bras
dans l'eau au saport pompiers qui l'ont
apporté sur la berge et qui ont procédé
au au comment aux opérations de
ranimation sur cet enfant malgré
l'intervention des secours le petit
garçon en arrêt cardioespiratoire n'a
pas pu être réanimé une enquête de
gendarmerie a été ouverte selon les
premiers témoignages un défaut de
surveillance se à l'origine du
drame